head over to
losingmymind.com to check out our latest
song genocide support our work now onto
the show
let's talk about Kanye West we have this
uh tweet Kanye says what what should be
obvious by now is that I was raised to
stand for my truth regardless of the
consequences so I will say this again I
was mentally misdiagnosed and nearly
drugged out of my mind to make me a
manageable well-behaved celebrity here's
a text he posted from someone named
Harley that says I'm going to help you
one of a couple ways first you and I sit
down and have a have an loving and open
conversation but you don't use cuss
words and everything that is discussed
is based in fact and not some crazy
stuff that dumb friend of yours told you
or you saw in a tweet second option I
have you institutionalized again where
they medicate the crap out of you and
you go back to Zombieland forever play
date with the kids just won't be the
same wow that's evil I just it's that's
insane man
that's scary stuff it's also blackmail I
think I don't know who this person is
what kind of power they have well I
don't even know if the Texas doctor to
be honest but I don't think Kanye would
lie but I don't know I was watching
Nathan for you because he's got a he's
got he's got a new show coming out so
like HBO put him on the front page and I
saw it I'm like yeah I've never watched
it so I did
uh for those that are familiar with the
show he says that he like graduated from
business school and he wants to help
businesses get new customers it's not
true it's just a funny reality show it's
comedy he goes to a TV shop
that's losing business because of Best
Buy and so he says here's what we're
going to do we are going to exploit Best
Buy's price match policy we're going to
sell your TVs for a dollar then go to
Best Buy and say see look they're for a
dollar so we can buy all your TVs
the problem is how do you stop people
from actually buying the TVs for a
dollar because you'd lose them all so he
requires them to wear a tuxedo dress
code to come into the store this is what
Nathan Nathan Fielder does then he says
if they actually shove in tuxedo they
have to crawl through a tiny door two
feet tall on the ground if they make it
through there the TVs are in a room with
an alligator
and it's just it's absolutely insane
it's it's hilarious show
now he says I'm worried that the guy is
going to get sued by Best Buy I know how
to prevent him from from that happening
a legal Insanity diagnosis
he goes to a psychiatrist and he says my
friend is insane he thinks he's a
manager and electronics store and is not
and I want you to talk to him
so she's talking to him and says how are
you and he says you know it's great I
work in an electronic store I've been
doing it she goes oh and you like him
goes yes and she goes oh okay and then
Nathan says ask him about the alligator
and then she goes oh I didn't know and
then he starts explaining this story
about people in tuxedos crawling through
two foot doors and then getting scared
of an alligator and then she says he's
psychotic he's completely detached from
reality and that was a that was scary I
mean the show's really really funny but
that story right there I think is really
important because what's what you what
you have with Kanye is that he can say
something he says things that are
outrageous don't get me wrong but you
could say something that people don't
believe and then they could
institutionalize you and Drug you and
lock you up and have everyone believe
that you're nuts and then the crazy
thing is he's saying he was nearly
drugged out of his mind some of the
crazy things he may have been saying was
because they were pumping him full of
crazy drugs yeah
I know that it came out in the Lex
Freeman podcast with yay that he was
exhausted it was like a he had a bout of
exhaustion that landed him in the
hospital and they treated it like a
mental diagnosis
and that's the whole thing remember from
like four years ago and it's like oh
Kanye was in the hospital and that's
when they were drugging him I guess a
lot of these big Pharma pills have a lot
of unintended consequences especially
when it comes to messing with your brain
chemistry which is not an exact science
each person has a different brain
chemistry each person's brain works
different than the other person so just
throwing pills at it I mean this would
explain some of the kind of more manic
behavior by Kanye especially if if he
has just been given pills or even worse
forced to take pills and this could also
explain why a lot of people are having
psychotic breakdowns especially in
Hollywood uh you know and and this could
be a big conspiracy here that that he's
unraveling that I think is worth paying
attention to because when when we look
at doctors when we look at big Pharma
they have a lot of power when it comes
to the individual and they could they
could force you to take drugs that could
mess you up for the rest of your life
and just like this this guy says he'll
make sure that play dates with the kids
just won't be be the same I mean that's
real life consequences for the rest of
his life and and you're saying that he's
going to be medicated forever so this is
this is a big deal this is this is
something worth talking about I also
feel like there was so much sympathy for
Britney Spears with free Brittany which
I agree with but I just don't think
Kanye's gonna get the same thing because
he's been remotely Maga I mean I don't
even think he's you know it's
conservative in every way like you were
saying people kind of can be free
thinkers I think he is a free thinker he
has certain views on certain things and
I don't think that people are going to
Rally behind him if he's being forced to
take drugs because of his political
views when I think a lot of people
rallied behind free Brittany
yeah yeah he tweeted that he's he's what
is all the stuff he's posting
oh is he going after people now oh man
he's a sweet story by name yeah I'm
looking at his Twitter right now I'm
trying to read it it's a lot of
information well that's what Lex Freeman
incursion but he's like rather than just
scream about an ethnic group of people
name people name them yeah go for it I
don't think they canceled him because of
that I think it was because of political
stuff I think that was just an excuse
they were like oh great now here's a
great example of why we can cancel him
well you know I don't think that's what
it was I mean Harry you know Prince
Harry Harry and Megan like he wore a
Nazi outfit it's like we can go through
people and come up with reasons to
cancel them but it's like come on I mean
they obviously just don't like his
political views yeah and then there's uh
Northam we're not sure if he was the guy
in blackface or the guy in the clown
outfit but you know one of the two right
and they didn't cancel him yep I think
uh you look you look back in time
what they learned the government the
intelligence agencies is that
assassinations are a bad idea
you know it Martyrs people it makes
their their ideas last forever and so
look at what look what they're doing to
Julian Assange
you lock them up in a tiny room so he
can't work so he struggles to work you
claim he's crazy you accuse him of being
of bad moral character and then you let
him just wither away effectively killing
him very very slowly but then you don't
get a martyr then they start
manipulating The Narrative and then make
sure as many people as possible hates
you and now they've convinced the
younger generation that Julian's
actually a bad guy so they have these
young Democrat voters who don't like him
I think that is what the left wants to
do and I think that's what they're doing
to the January 6th there's a lot of them
are in solitary confinement totally
suffering many of them literally zero
violence walked inside and so on but
they just want to slowly kill them
because solitary confinement does drive
people crazy forcing people to take
drugs of course that's going to make you
crazy that's the goal of the drug to
alter your brain so I I definitely think
that the left doesn't want to make it
into a spectacle because yes then
they'll be a martyr I mean I think in
some ways that's what happened with
Trump they were like we're going to raid
Mar-A-Lago all this stuff they realized
oh my gosh now Trump has more sport than
ever everybody is obsessed with Trump
trump 2.0 so they're not going to do
that to a lot of these other people
they'd rather just have them slowly
wither away
that's the ubliet is the old torture
well torture chamber it's an old prison
cell French means to forget and they
would just throw people down a hole wow
yeah and then what you just slowly dive
dehydration or they pull you out
eventually and put you back in the cell
and be like if you do that again you're
going back in the ubli yet is there
water in the ublia they would just dump
stuff down there they'd be laying on
like dead rats dead dead human bodies
would be in the with them they'd be
laying there they'd like pour buckets
down jeez they'd defecate all of
themselves I mean it was the worst of
the worst torturous prison cell and
anyone could do it at any time a lot of
a lot of castles have a newbliet and now
you know social media Banning someone on
social media it's kind of like hopefully
they forget about them I think that's
what they did with Trump they were like
now that he's gone his influence won't
be won't be permeating but they need
Trump
yeah they need the boogeyman yeah they
tried doing DeSantis it didn't work they
tried doing Tucker Tucker is the new
Trump and like no he's really not you
know without Trump but he gives Jennifer
Lawrence nightmares he does yeah I don't
want to think that Donald Trump
resembles like a politic he's just a guy
he's a really unique guy but wasn't
wasn't Jennifer Lawrence's nightmares
that like she was being chased by a bear
and a big manly Tucker Carlson ripped
his shirt off and then fought the bear
off and saved her and then like they
swung from a vine to you know
like she never said the nightmare was
that she was scared of Tucker you know
what I mean like maybe the nightmare was
Joe Biden was coming up behind her and
then Tucker jumps into and saves the day
yeah well she's just trying to get a
sniff you know that's how her family or
like people she knew from her home she's
too old because she's from like Middle
America or Republican and that like
freaks her out to think that any of them
would ever watch Tucker Carlson she's
probably like oh my gosh you guys are
brainwashed and so I think her her whole
goal was to say how you know people who
watch Tucker are basically total idiots
hmm yeah and a lot of people watch them
compared to the Old Guard as he's I I
think he's the number one if I'm wrong
in all of the United States when it
comes to news reporting and you know
he's someone that again also criticized
Donald Trump in many instances called
him out for for a lot of actions but
he's able to to say things that of
course a lot of people can't even say
online so that's another aspect to why
he might be so popular because he's on
television which oddly now is a little
bit more of a free place than the
internet when it comes to online speech
it used to be the inverse of that but
now we have this space where he says a
lot of things that really has your
eyebrows uh rising up but is it because
he's got big money Fox advertising
behind him that Google won't ban there
was a lot of advertisement boycotts
against him uh yeah he lost a ton of
advertisers they're they're still even
on you know when I watch this program
there's still segments where they don't
have any advertisers and they just do
the kind of Fox music so my pillow uh
it's only my pillow yeah some big Pharma
ads and then RV ads I saw on there but
then other than that is just like a
blank screen like hold on we'll be back
with Tucker we should advertise our
Tucker we'll just be like hey you're
watching this show turn it off go to
youtube.comcast irons
I think his show is also just so much
better than so many other shows on TV so
if you're going to turn on a show in
that realm I think that's the show to
watch because he has like interesting
content I think so many other people who
have those jobs just don't have
interesting comments you can watch
something all day and it's literally
like the same thing the same story I I
saw him get humiliated by uh Jon Stewart
when he came in with a bow ties a long
time ago and it I gained so much respect
for Tucker having gone through that in
public like being publicly humiliated
and just like eating it and being like
you know I'm not perfect and he would
like address his own weaknesses he
became a way better journalist after
that and willing to listen to opposing
view he's always kind of liked opposing
views but he really became like an
impressive man after he got where he was
by debating and having conversations
with the opposition thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com come for uncensored
members only shows exclusive thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time